[Music]
my name is Kai Lenny and today I'm going
to teach you how to stand up paddleboard
[Music]
stand-up paddling is one of the fastest
growing sports in the entire world and
it's one of the most fun
it's a traditional Hawaiian sport and
throughout the world people are really
taking to it any body of water you can
imagine you can always have fun and the
most important parts get the best
workout so in my hands right here is the
paddle typically paddle lengths will
vary it's a comfortable arm length
you know just above my head where if I
were to just do a shot go on my head it
would reach the top of the teeth luckily
for us we have a t-handle it really
allows you for better leverage and saves
a lot of your energy got the board which
is obviously the most important part
because without the board you can't
stand on water
vanna paddle boards are a little bigger
than the traditional surfboard when
learning I would say you just want to be
comfortable so I'm going to give you
three key points to remember while santa
paddling they're simple and easy but
they'll help you a lot in the long run
[Music]
then a paddling is all about balance
it's important to be able to keep that
balance one suggestion would be keeping
your eyes evenly on the horizon line and
especially keeping your stance in that
comfortable zone and then it'll the
board if I line my toes up directly with
the front of the handle that is the
comfiest faut that's like the zone you
want to be standing and if he starts
feeling stable
remember you have a paddle here you can
use it as your crutch for stability
remember it's always important to have
the scoop of the paddle facing away from
you the reason for that is because the
actual flat part of your paddle will
create more power throughout the water
whereas the scoop will actually just
move water out of its way and thus
making you work harder and lose more
energy and remember the most important
thing never pass your feet and the
reason for this is when you're paddling
through the water and you reach your
feet the blade will be at 90 degrees
with your leg anything past your feet
you're wasting energy and slowing
yourself down so like I like to say keep
everything up in front stand-up paddling
is the most simple sport in the world
but the beautiful thing about it is
there's really no limit you can
constantly push yourself to the next
level and for me that's why I really
love it you know those three things will
take you a long way instead of paddling
now that we've gotten the flat water
thing figured out let's go catch a wave
[Music]
you want to see me do more cool stuff
check out me kite surfing windsurfing
and Santa paddleboarding in a suit on
the GQ Channel